Doctor Strange is finally here to blow our
minds with another mystical side of the Marvel
universe.
We're introduced to a host of new characters
that inhabit the hidden world of sorcerers
and infinite dimensions, but if all these
new faces have you confused, don't worry.
We're here to help sort it out.
Here's a look at characters in Doctor Strange
who mean more than you realized.
Baron Mordo
Considering he's Dr. Strange's closest ally
and the Ancient One's top pupil, Karl Mordo's
sudden heel turn in the post-credits scene
might have come as a surprise to some people.
But it's all part of Marvel's master plan.
See, in the comics, Mordo is also Strange's
arch-enemy.
In fact, the plot of the film is based on
a famous storyline that saw Mordo, rather
than Kaecilius, betray the Ancient One in
an attempt to curry favor with Dormammu.
In a way, everything that happens in this
movie is just setting the stage for Mordo's
villainy in future films.
Wong
As the librarian at Kamar-Taj, Wong is kind
of a strict guy, seemingly incapable of laughter,
but secretly harboring a love of Beyonce.
But you can expect to see a lot more of him
in future films: in the comics, Wong is Doctor
Strange's steadfast partner and best friend.
We look forward to seeing Wong and Stephen's
friendship blossom in future films—and we
can't wait to see Wong open up more cans of
butt-kicking action with the Kamar-Taj style
of martial arts.
Nicodemus West
While he wasn't given much screen time, Strange's
colleague and rival Dr. Nicodemus West is
a little more interesting than he seems.
"I guess I'll just have to just stick with
Nick."
"Oh wait a minute.
You're not…
You guys aren't."
"What"
"Sleeping together.
Sorry, I thought that was implicit in my disgust."
"Ex, explicit actually."
In the comics, as in the film, he operated
on Strange's hands after his accident, leaving
them with nerve damage.
But in the comics, he also later followed
Strange to Kamar-Taj and trained in the magic
arts as well.
It suggests that there may be more to his
appearance in the movie than we first thought...
Christine Palmer
A surgeon and a former flame to Stephen Strange,
Christine Palmer also has her own long and
bizarre history in the comics.
She appeared as one of the main characters
in the Night Nurse comics, which also inspired
Rosario Dawson's character in Marvel's line
of Netflix shows, and later even had a romance
with Nightcrawler from the X-Men.
It's fairly certain we won't see Rachel McAdams
appear as Dr. Palmer in any X-Men films, but
we look forward to seeing her return in future
Doctor Strange adventures.
Cloak of Levitation
In Doctor Strange, the Cloak of Levitation
is an ancient magical relic with a mind of
its own, choosing to help Strange by protecting
him while he was under attack from Dormammu's
zealots.
In the comics, the Cloak of Levitation was
a gift from the Ancient One, and has even
helped Doctor Strange save the universe a
time or two.
But while it's powerful, it just doesn't quite
have the same personality that it does in
the movie.
"It likes you."
Dormammu
"Dormammu, I've come to bargain!"
Those are words you'll likely hear a lot from
Doctor Strange fans.
While Strange might have been successful in
annoying the demon lord of the Dark Dimension
into submission, he didn't actually kill him.
It's also important to note that the bargain
Strange made with Dormammu said that the demon
would have to leave Earth alone, but it didn't
say anything about Strange leaving the Dark
Dimension alone.
And since Doctor Strange's one true love in
the comics, Clea, is actually Dormammu's niece
and eventual successor as ruler of the Dark
Dimension, it's a fair bet we'll see Dormammu
again — and this time, on his terms.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!